bonsoir a tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver au sommaire de savon garde ce
soir ne céder ni aux amalgames réducteur
ni aux protections coupable c'est par
ces mots qu emmanuel macron a défini sa
ligne sur les violences au sein de la
police et le racisme
cette ligne de crête est elle tenable
nous en parlerons avec eric ciotti le
député les républicains remettait aussi
un rapport attendu ce matin à
l'assemblée sur les dysfonctionnements à
l'origine de l'attentât fin 2019 au
coeur de la préfecture de police de
paris
c'est une crise grave très grave dont on
parle trop peu
cela fait maintenant un mois que la
presse n'est plus distribué dans tout le
sud est de la france la faute aux
coronavirus mais pas seulement la
faillite de presstalis et y est pour
beaucoup le principal distributeur de
journaux en france est officiellement en
cessation de paiement alors que va-t-il
se passer pour vos magazines pour vos
journaux décryptage à suivre dans un
instant enfin le jour d'après nouvel
épisode de notre collection d'entretien
sur les leçons à tirer de cette crise
sanitaire ce soir les selistes david
djaïz nous parle du retour en force des
états nation voilà donc pour le
programme c'est parti hashtag cvr
n'oubliez pas où il va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
bonsoir eric ciotti merci infiniment
d'être sur ce plateau beaucoup de sujets
dont l'actualité la question du racisme
dans la police et les violences
policières il ya encore eu des
manifestations
hier le gouvernement sous le feu des
enquêtes et notamment la vôtre puisque
vous êtes le rapporteur de la commission
d' enquête sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire c'est le co vide dont on va
parler tout à l'heure mais on va
commencer avec le risque terroriste vous
avez rendu ce matin votre rapport d'
enquête sur les failles à la préfecture
de police de paris après la tuerie à
l'armé blanche de michael harpon c'était
en octobre 2019 on commence par là vous
connaissez stéphane blakowski et bien
voilà accueillir tout de suite il fait
pencher sur votre rapport si j'ai bien
compris tout de suite pour myriam soir
bonsoir stéphane si j'ai bien compris ce
soir ben si j'ai bien compris myriam la
police c'est un peu comme une grande
famille donc eric ce type devrait pas me
contredire puisque c'est à peu près les
mots qu'il a employés en octobre 2019
en ouverture d'une séance de la
commission qui enquête sur la pratique
heures de police donc je vous propose de
réécouter ses quelques mots nous pensons
à leurs familles nous pensons aussi à
leurs collègues à tous ceux qui ont été
touché au coeur par cette attaque
nous pensons aux familles et à la grande
famille des polices alors sur le coup
c'est l'idée que la police forme une
famille ça m'a un peu surpris mais je me
suis dit bon bah c'est plutôt une
formule simplement qu'on peut à eric
ciotti pour pour marquer son soutien à
cette grande institution qu'est la
police nationale et puis en fait je me
suis rendu compte que vous n'étiez pas
le seul à considérer que la police est
une grande famille parmi les janvier ont
été interrogées par la commission il y
avait michel delpech l'ancien préfet de
police de paris
et il disait pareil disaient les
services de police sont une grande
famille comme décidemment dit dès que la
police est une grande famille c'est que
c'est assez répandu un mais ça s'arrête
pas là il ya plusieurs collègues du
terroriste michael harpon justement qui
ont été interrogées par la commission et
qui décrivait que dans le service où
travaillait la drpp y régnait
une ambiance familiale et selon député
c'est justement cette ambiance familiale
qui a empêché que on signale à la
hiérarchie le fait qu'on avait repéré
des signes de radicalisation chez
michael harpon alors je vous lis ce que
disent les députés disent la capacité de
discernement des collègues de mickaël
larpe on a été influencé par l'ambiance
familiale qui règne dans son service une
unité de petite taille où la plupart des
agents avaient fait venir un fils une
cousine ou un collègue avec qui il avait
des affinités
alors là ça devient carrément
embarrassant j'ai l'impression peine
croyable alliée à la partie tueur de
police il vaut donc mieux avoir un beau
coup de piston plutôt que des
compétences c'est quand même très gênant
parce que en fait ça commence à faire
réfléchir à ça veut dire quoi cette
histoire que la police nationale est
comme une grande famille moi je me mets
à réfléchir mais si mon frère par
exemple comme était une infraction très
grave
évidemment que j'hésiterais quand même
un peu le dénoncer parce que j'imagine
que dans comme dans beaucoup de familles
les liens qui qui nous unissent sont
plus forts que les règlements ou les
lois qui s'appliquent à tout le monde et
c'est là que ça devient très embêtant
parce que si mon collègue dans la police
c'est un peu comme mon frère ou ma
famille le jour où un petit délinquant
le provoque la grèce et qui commence à y
mettre des claques
est-ce que je vais le dénoncer ce qu'ils
m'ont collé que c'est comme mon frère et
qui m'aident commence à vraiment cogner
trop fort sur ce délinquant est ce que
je vais oser dénoncer c'est pas évident
parce que ce qui risque d'arriver c'est
que si je dénonce mon collègue c'est moi
qui vais me retrouver mis au ban de la
famille parce que je n'aurais pas été
solidaires donc j'imagine que vous voyez
où je veux en venir
et ça m'a fait penser à quelque chose
qui m'avait vraiment choqué pour le coup
la map à un peu embarrassé vraiment
choqué c'est ce que disait assa traoré
donc à third à damas lors de la fameuse
manifestation vous avoir ces propos sont
un petit peu confus mais on comprend
qu'en fait ce qu'elle veut dire
aujourd'hui on nous avons une policière
qui est dans l'impunité totale
tu sais qui est aujourd'hui nous avons
une policière qui ne fait pas super à
une police qui se considère comme une
mafia
hier france entière elle fait ce qu'elle
veut il n'y a aucune
ouais mélange un petit peu les mobiles
skis l'hyper chaud quand est ce qu'on
comprend très bien c'est qu'elle compare
la police à une mafia et c'est ça qui
m'a choqué parce que principe de la
mafia c'est quoi c'est justement des
grandes familles de voyous des clans
chez qui le lien du sang est tellement
important que sa prime sur toutes les
autres loin c'est souvent ce qui fait
leur force
or évidemment évidemment que la police
n'est pas une mafia
c'est hyper choquant ce qu'il ya c'est
vrai et c'est une de nos plus grandes
institutions elle ne doit donc
évidemment pas fonctionné sur les
principes de la famille lors quand on
dit et qu'on répète et tout le monde a
l'air de l'accepter que la police est
une grande famille moi je trouve ça
gênant parce que ça tend à faire croire
que les liens qui unissent les policiers
entre eux sont plus forts que les lois
qui doivent s'appliquer à tous ceux qui
pour rebondir sur le papier de tes fans
et revenir sur votre rapport c'est
extrêmement critique sur le
fonctionnement de la pp comme on
l'appelle la préfecture de police de
paris
c'est une institution dans l'institution
une forme de clans à part dans la police
c'est une histoire spécifique c'est vrai
qu'il y a des règles il ya une forme
d'indépendance un lien privilégié
historique entre le président de la
république et le préfet de police qui
d'ailleurs souvent contourne le ministre
de l'intérieur donc il ya cette
spécificité mais pour revenir à notre
commission denquête bon il y avait un
mot générique dix ans où je rendait
hommage à la famille de la police après
c'était en fonction aussi du traumatisme
qui a été subie qui était inédit quatre
morts au sein de la préfecture de police
assassiné par un des leurs ce qu'on
appelle une attaque bleus sur bleu donc
le traumatisme était fort et on l'a
perçue dans les auditions on a
auditionné des collègues qui ont
travaillé depuis plusieurs années dans
le même bureau avec harpon qui était
naturellement choqué je comprends cette
émotion ce que vous expliquer ce qu'il
n'aurait jamais dû rester en employé
d'un service aujourd'hui aux cibles
plusieurs femmes la préfecture de nos
familles mais après quand le mot fanni
c'est bien finalement le facteur qui
explique que la solidarité des policiers
entre fonds qui s'affranchissent des
règles qui ne signale même pas qu'un
excellent les qualités
y avait cette situation particulière qui
peut être dû certains nous l'ont dit moi
j'ai pas de de position définitive liées
au handicap de mickaël larpe ont aussi
qu'ils ont mais ce qu'on a constaté
pour résumer très très brièvement harpon
n'aurait jamais dû rester dans une
direction du renseignement
voilà ode à la nature de police la drpp
c'est un service de lutte contre le
terrorisme
c'est un service de renseignement et il
a émis durant plusieurs années
et avant que les faits ne se produise
une multitude de signaux sa pratique
religieuse est devenu beaucoup plus
rigoristes il ne faisait plus la bise à
certaines de ses collègues sont ces
comportements se sont modifiés ils ont
été perçus par moment de l'attentât
le point d'orgue quelques jours après
charlie où il a une altercation quasi
physique ça nous a été décrit avec un de
ses collègues où il justifie d'attentât
et il dit c'est bien fait en regardant
son écran où il regardait des images qui
décrivait l'attentât il dit c'est bien
fait c'est l'accumulation de ces
éléments auraient du sila la drpp avait
fonctionné comme un service avec une
exigence de sécurité tel qu'on l'a
retrouvé à la dgse bien sûr mais mais
aussi à la dgs si c'est à dire que
beaucoup de directeurs nous on dit chez
nous pas une seconde il serait resté
voilà donc il y arrive
nous avons été sidérés le rapport ce
matin a été approuvé à l'unanimité un de
madame le pen aux représentants de la
france un soubise donc ces voix là j'ai
présidé une commission qu'il est avec le
rapporteur florent boudié nous avons été
totalement phase nous le sommes sur les
conclusions nous le sommes sur les
propositions qu on dit on ne comprend
pas et on aimait des propositions pour
que ça change alors geste est membre de
l'ades au delà du constat de cette
faillite collective s'est élevé
au gré de ses gosses qu'il faut retirer
la lutte antiterroriste des compétences
de la préfecture de police est ce qu'il
faut pas aller jusqu'à supprimer
totalement cette fameuse drpp direction
du renseignement de la préfecture de
coyah deux pistes émises par le
rapporteur soit la suppression totale de
la drpp soit une que personnellement je
privilégie c'est à dire que tout ce qui
relève de la lutte contre le terrorisme
soit rattachée à la dgsi moi je suis
partisan d'organisations et
d'institutions centralisée quand il ya
deux acteurs on a déjà le problème de la
coordination c'est ce qui a touché le
ministère de l'intérieur depuis des
années on a multiplié les structures et
comment à multiplier les structures on a
multiplié les instances de coordination
des gares de services ans au plus au
clac avec des luttes en effet des
concurrences des informations des
informations qui sont perdus donc quand
on a qu'une unité quand on entend les
centraliser la détente et à la cjce a
une expertise à une expérience un
professionnalisme qui aujourd'hui
reconnu d'ailleurs depuis quelques mois
c'est le chef de file reconnu par tous
de la lutte contre le terrorisme peut
plus enrayer cette idée de
centralisation elle vient d'où elle
vient de nicolas sarkozy en 2008
quand il crée la direction centrale du
renseignement intérieur qui regroupe les
anciens renseignements généraux les
rejets et la dst s'est il a la bonne
idée poursuivi m
tous les gouvernements poursuivent et
quand même tout 22 élections qui ont été
faites dans la fermera on s'est dit
tiens on a tout centraliser et
finalement les policiers de terrain qui
eux peuvent parfois repérer des choses
on ne les écoute plus donc on a
l'impression qu'on sait tout mieux faire
que et on rate des impôts vous dit le
médecin l'idée il y a eu ses critiques
elle était aussi souvent animées par des
considérations un peu politique mais la
bonne idée c'était celle-là et
d'ailleurs personne de la remise en
cause pas plus aucun gouvernement de
françois hollande
aucun gouvernement des manuels à cran
parce que et au contraire tout
tous les gouvernements ont fait en sorte
que cette convergence aille encore plus
loin et donc aujourd'hui faut franchir
cette étape pour connais pas deux
services de renseignements intérieurs
sur le territoire national home pour la
plaque parisienne par une réforme
structurelle renseignements faux cette
structure cette réforme structurelle
donc on dit un harpon n'aurait jamais dû
rester à la préfecture de police
il faut élever le degré d'exigence a été
fait a notamment par la direccte
renforcer les enquêtes admise dans la
série tu fais un bon travail et je mets
pas en cause aujourd'hui
en tout cas il aurait jamais vaincu les
nouvelles maisons
il faut aller plus loin il faut sans
doute une réforme structurelle et puis
un autre sujet aussi parce que et je les
points étaient personnellement dans le
rapport il a fréquenté un imam ça a été
dit dans la presse l' enquête judiciaire
n'a ligonnès est pas notre
responsabilité quel rôle il a joué mais
cet imam il avait fait l'objet d'une
obligation de quitter le territoire
français
ils étaient fichés moi je dis
systématiquement qu'une personne qui
représente qu'on considère comme étant
susceptibles de représenter menace pour
la sécurité nationale
quand elle est étrangère quand elle est
inscrite au fichier des signes à l'époux
radicalisation terroristes elle ne doit
pas rester en france
il a été condamné il a fait l'objet
d'une lettre aux légations quitter le
territoire ils n'auraient jamais dû
rester en france on va harpon n'aurait
jamais dû être à la préfecture de police
de paris
l'imam n'aurait jamais dû être enfant on
va avancer deux éléments avaient été
impliqués y aurait pas eu le temps on va
parler des violences policières dans un
instant mais on est dans une période
très particulière sort à peine de la
crise sanitaire il ya une longue période
de conflit de mon crise économique crise
sociale qui se profile où en est la
menace terroriste dans un moment comme
celui-là lé elle est toujours là on l'a
vu même en période de confinement il ya
eu deux attentats notamment à romans sur
isère
nous sommes dans une période de
fragilité national avec de l'inquiétude
avec une crise sociale et donc avec sans
doute une plus grande vulnérabilité
aussi donc il ne faut pas baisser la
garde la menace islamiste
elle est là il y à ce qui s'est passé je
salue l'action nos services au mali avec
la neutralisation des trous belle
qui était le leader d'aqmi il y a
la réorganisation de l'état islamique
nos services le dise aujourd'hui il y a
cette montée de l'islamisme dans nos
dans nos quartiers qui est de plus en
plus prégnante donc la menace elle est
toujours là et en aucun cas il ne faut
baisser la garde
si une femme et c'est la garde non plus
et on avance sur la question du racisme
dans la police chez certains c'est un
autre sujet est un autre sujet mais on
va en parler à présent c'est certes un
policier il y a un problème ou pas selon
vous d'abord moi je ne dirais pas qu'il
ya un problème spécifique à la police le
racisme en soi est une abomination d'où
qu'ils viennent qu'ils viennent de
certains membres de la police qu'ils
viennent de journalistes qu'ils viennent
de politiques qu'ils viennent de
n'importe lequel vous avez à des groupes
et laurent qui rassemble la fumée la
police de racisme échangent des propos
racistes alors racisme est un délit
c'est une abomination c'est contraire à
tout ce que la france issu des lumières
exprime un tout autre humanité alors une
fois qu'on a mis quatre dans la fois une
fois qu'on a dit ça je ne veux pas qu'on
stigmatise la police j'ai entendu des
propos est tout à l'heure il y avait ces
images qui me révolte en hissant la
police est une mafia
on a entendu la police et et racistes
ont entendu des artistes des pseudos
artistes en mal de notoriété dire que la
police massacre et massacré des citoyens
mais moi je crois la police républicaine
la police elle nous elle nous protège
qu'il y ait des comportements
inacceptables vous évoquez ce groupe
facebook avec des propos qui ont été
relatées par la presse qui sont indignes
des dizaines et des dizaines de
témoignages particuliers y avait un fond
de racisme systémique c'est à dire que
coûte mais c'est malgré tout un
interlocuteur on peut respecter jacques
toubon président sait que l approche
télé
les contrôles d'identité où on avait
l'enquêté pas plus de chance d'être
contrôlé quand on était un homme un
jeune homme
j'aperçois on va revoir à jacques toubon
s'est fait une spécialité depuis
quelques années sans doute pour faire
oublier sa tendre jeunesse d'attaquer
systématiquement l'institution policière
j'ai eu l'occasion de lui dire en
commission des lois
c'est une appréciation qui me paraît
assez éloigné de l'objectivité
voilà nous avons besoin d'une police
souvent contrôlés que les autres c'est
quand même un problème a priori ou alors
on a su dire que les policiers
contrôlent le en cas de suspicion d'un
délit donc qu'ils contrôlent ce qu'ils
ont en face pas en fonction de leur
couleur de peau en fonction des actes
qui sont contre il n'y a pas deux il n'y
a pas de contrôles au faciès la police
et et républicains dont je récuse la
caméra piétons le reste justement pour
sécuriser aussi les policiers parce que
nous avons vu et vous avez raison de
citer ses actes ses propos qui choquent
il y a eu des actes de hip hop qui
peuvent relever de violence individuelle
qui sont d'ailleurs sanctionné il y as d
enquête de l'igpn il y en a eu mille
quatre cents l'année dernière ils ne
dérangent pas forcément serein ce que
toutes ne sont des prophètes toutes ne
sont pas justifiées mais
systématiquement lorsque cela est
nécessaire la justice est saisie il y a
des révocations il y à des condamnations
quelle profession est aussi contrôlé que
la police donc on fait rien de plus je
pose la question quelle mesure je suis
très favorable à et lamerat piéton passe
à renforcer les éléments de sécurité
pour les citoyens c'est un élément de
sécurité pour les policiers aussi pour
sécuriser leurs procédures parce que
très souvent certains délectant etc et
malheureusement les propos sur la
suspicion avéré qui est une abominable
ération une aberration juridique une
suspicion va conduire à la suspension
des policiers en cas de suspicion avait
rétabli la loi qu'est ce que robespierre
la loi des suspects c'est quoi
on est dans un état de droit il faut
qu'ils aient une enquête il faut qu'ils
du contradictoire il faut que ce soit
prouvée discours dont ça s'est passé
dans notre droit
c'est une c'est une expression suspicion
avérée de racisme employé à dessein
mais parmi les de l'intérieur où c'est
une maladresse ben ça veut dire que
d'abord c'est une notion juridique qui
n'existe pas qui n'existe pas on est
dans un état de droit
le ministre de l'intérieur il a en
charge du reste le respect de la loi
mais quand on il nous dit qu'une
manifestation est interdite mais
l'émotion fait qu'elle ne sera plus
interdite
là aussi on est dans une notion de 2,4
de ses troupiers disent beaucoup en ce
moment vous y connaissez vraiment deux
mondes les policiers entendront beaucoup
en soit là que voilà que dans l'est que
dans les banlieues les quartiers les
cités comme on veut l'ambiance est plus
en plus tendu le confinement n'a pas
arrangé les choses et que la saison est
vraiment explosive
il ya peut-être aussi un acte fort ou
des gages à donner pour ne pas remettre
encore de lui sans le free mais avec
cette attitude que vous développez on
établit dans notre pays un état de droit
différent selon les territoires
moi je considère que la loi elle doit
s'appliquer pour tous et partout sur le
territoire de la république si une
manifestation est interdite parce qu'on
est dans un risque pandémique majeur qui
rappelons le a causé 30 mille morts donc
le gouvernement a pris des décisions on
interdit d'aider rassemblement de 10
personnes on est des hélicoptères qui
surveillaient encore quelques jours si
quelqu'un allait mettre une serviette
suis alors lâche de plusieurs qu'il
fallait faire laisse des rassemblements
de 30 personnes confirment confinement
il s'applique dans certains quartiers il
ne s'applique pas ailleurs et
concrètement qu'est ce que vous proposez
par seconde il ya des manifestations
l'application de la loi
après la verdeur d'une manifestation est
interdite
soit on l'autorisent soit on l'interdît
en tant qu'elle est interdite
cette idée de dire qu'il ya des lois
différentes
elle introduit une république
fracturation n'était pas question pour
nous de remy rassemblement il ya eu des
amendes
rappelez vous quand une personne sortait
de son domicile plus d'une heure il y
avait des amendes de 35 euros des 235
euros
on est encore sous ce régime moi je vis
on n'a que ça à donner au moment des
manifestations la cgt jaune
on a tous le maintien lors du palais
cannois où il fallait donc quand on
laisse prospérer cette idée qu'on peut
contourner la loi
on envoie un message extraordinairement
dangereux c'est très clair on va aborder
et on y était déjà d'une certaine
manière la question des violences
policières et du maintien de l'ordre à
pied tall à jeudi c'est important moi je
propose qu'il y ait systématiquement ses
caméras piétons interventions çà
sécurisera et le citoyen et le policier
bonsoir c'est khalil besner vous n'avez
pas malheureusement en chair et en os
sur ce plateau comme comme stéphane et
je le regrette bien volontiers géraldine
que vous connaissez qui est journaliste
au point et chroniqueuse dans cette
émission va parler des violences
policières question évidemment qu'ils
datent pas d'hier le gouvernement
d'edouard philippe n'est pas le premier
à s'y être confronté non et d'ailleurs
c'est assez frappant voir que les partis
de gouvernement finalement disent tous
la même chose alors oui il ya des
violences policières mais les dérives
individuelles rien de systémique
on comprends l'argument de gouvernement
débordé par des problèmes de délinquance
problèmes sociaux qu'ils ne savent pas
gérer la police c'est le dernier rempart
on va pas lui taper dessus mais du coup
on s'attaque pas aux problèmes qui
empire et nicolas sarkozy à l'époque n'a
rien fait pour le résoudre
quand il arrive au ministère de
l'intérieur en 2002 rappelez vous c'est
après une campagne menée par jacques
chirac sur le thème de l'insécurité pour
obtenir des résultats il instaure une
politique assumée deux chiffres la
police elle doit multiplier les
contrôles pas toujours efficaces en 5%
aboutissent seulement à une à une
arrestation
on multiplie les contrôles et en
contrepartie ils équipent cette police
il introduit les grenades de
désencerclement les lanceurs de balles
de défense dont on ne pense pas à
l'époque d'ailleurs qu'ils sont
dangereux ils en généralise usage en
2005 pendant les émeutes et la doctrine
de maintien de l'ordre change elle aussi
on va davantage au contact l'opinion à
l'époque est satisfaite la délinquance
recule mais le fossé se creuse avec une
partie de la population d'autant plus
peut-être que c'est nicolas sarkozy
aussi qu'il supprime la police de
proximité qui avait pour but justement
de renouer ce lien entre police et
population
alors dites-moi nicolas sarkozy pourtant
je me souviens qu'il avait aussi une
politique et un discours assez ferme
contre ces mêmes violences policières
absolument comme d'ailleurs nos
gouvernants d'aujourd'hui c'est la
tolérance zéro le problème c'est que
comme aujourd'hui et en dépit de ce que
dit monsieur santi on ne sait pas du
tout ce qu'il advient de ces plaintes la
transparence est incomplète on n'a
aucune idée des peines prononcées des
quantums de ses peines et cette opacité
rend les gens suspicieux opacité
maintenu par tout le monde
d'autres gouvernements autant plus
ajouter d'autres problèmes à leurs reçus
par exemple des statistiques ethniques
que souhaitait pourtant nicolas sarkozy
empêche de mesurer l'ampleur des délits
de faciès et ça nourrit inévitablement
les soupçons de racisme
le manque de moyens h/f de tendre tout
le monde les caméras dont parle monsieur
ciotti qui sont censés équiper les
forces de l'ordre
ben on en a commandé elle ne marche pas
elle non pas de batterie c'est du
mauvais de matériel aujourd'hui on a
l'impression qu'on a une hauteur de
dénis en espèce de déni qui est aussi
assez utile finalement pour cacher tout
ses banques
merci géraldine adam est ce qu'il n'est
pas temps de sortir de ce déni à une
commission denquête qui est demandée par
le groupe socialiste à l'assemblée
nationale sur ces violences policières à
ce qu'ils aient pas temps de tout
remettre à plat
arrêtons avec ce mot de violences
policières dans ce que dit madame
boesner il ya des
il ya des vérités que je partage et
notamment factuellement sur les caméras
elle a totalement raison dix mille
caméras ont été achetés par monsieur
castaner elle ne marchera pas elles ont
qu une heure et demie d'autonomie forcé
des caméras ça marche il ya dix 10
heures d'autonomie on a choisi le
mauvais matériel en tout cas dans la
police pas forcément dans la gendarmerie
qui a eu un autre
notre choix ou qui travaillent à d'autre
choix donc ça c'est c'est très important
après elle dit quelque chose que je
partage la police et le dernier rempart
oui c'est le dernier rempart pour notre
république et des fois quand je vois
certains mouvements je me dis que dans
dans ce qui se passe aujourd'hui dans
ces attaques
parce que ces attaques elles sont
organisées aussi elles viennent de
l'extrême gauche
elles viennent de ceux qui veulent
déstabiliser la société voit la ligue
noir qui dit qu'on est un pays
terroriste terroristes on voit que par
la violence certains veulent prendre la
conquérir des territoires
après sur nicolas seriez jamais des jeux
mais là je dois dire très clairement non
d'abord elle était interdite moi je
respecte je respecte la loi
j'ai même été hué à nice parce que en
dix ans tout le monde déteste la police
et tout le monde était ce jeudi moi
j'aime la police j'aime la police parce
qu'on a besoin de la police la police
elle nous protège et il faut aussi
protéger ce qui nous protège savez
chaque jour relève vous reconnaissez qui
entraîne chômage est aujourd'hui il est
très loin des mollahs malaise - charlie
hebdo sur conseils tomber dans le radar
de cette image de ce policier ce crs de
couleurs qui était embrassé par un si
bon jour il y en à quoi un policier de
couleurs qui est traité de vendu dans
les manifestations où ils racisme il
faut qu'on le dénonce de tous les côtés
je le disais au départ et il ya du
racisme aussi qui s'exprime dans ses
mots dans ses mouvements sur les
techniques de maintien de l'ordre de
manière assez concrète
christophe castaner a interdit donc ces
techniques d'étranglement
mais pas le placage centrale qui restent
une mesure une technique qui est
possible et surtout pas les ailes bds
qui n'est pas temps d'interdire ces
fameux lanceurs de balles de défense
il a aussi proposé d'utiliser à la pl
si on supprime cette technique est ce
qui reste pour l'interpellation il faut
quand même rappeler que si les policiers
font usage de la force
c'est parce que ce qu'ils interpellent
et donc il ya une suspicion d'un délit
son délit de fuite ont refusé
d'obtempérer ont refusé de se soumettre
à la contrainte légitime donc vous
défendre je défends pas le lb je défends
les techniques d'interpellation et qui
sont prévus pour menotter un individu
qui ne respectent pas le l'injonction
d'obtempérer le lève le lb c'est autre
chose web d'aider la hausse il faudrait
qu est une caméra qui puisse contrôler
les tirs parce que la problématique
c'est les tirs à niveau du visage
il faut qu'on forme mieux les policiers
à peine douze heures de formation par an
aux techniques d'interpellation à l
usage de ces armes
c'est ridicule et surveiller les
policiers utilisent personnes position
habilité mais rappelez vous de ces
chiffres trente policiers blessés par
jour en mission cent sept policiers
chaque jour agressé dans le rapport de
l'igpn
il est indiqué qu'il y avait eu en
france 110 personnes blessées l'année
dernière par des policiers 110 avec une
itt était un délit de tous les côtés
sans d'un côté pour une année sans par
jour pour les policiers rééquilibrer un
peu les termes du débat parce qu'une
société sans police c'est la loi de la
jungle et de la barbarie qui
s'imposerait c'est pas ma france et
c'est pas cette france que je veux aller
pour terminer je voudrais qu'on évoque
la gestion de la crise sanitaire la
commission denquête dont vous êtes le
rapporteur a commencé ses travaux
enquête parlementaire ou enquête
politique dans la majorité certains
députés s'inquiètent du fait que vous
pourriez couper des têtes écouter
marie-christine verdier joucla on sait
pertinemment que quand on confie ce rôle
aux républicains forcément qui est un
coup politique à faire on les connaît et
que de ce fait qu'ils allaient choisir
un rapporteur mais qu'ils soient bien
marquer dans cette opposition qui se
veut un peu destructrice c'est à dire
qui veut absolument mettre à mal le
gouvernement est prouvé par a plus b que
toutes les décisions que nous avons
prises n'étaient pas les bonnes donc
dans la mesure où on le savait à
l'avancé si vraiment craignais je pense
que peut-être qu'on ne l'aurait pas fait
alors est ce que vous voulez faire
tomber des têtes eric ciotti vitoria je
pense que fernand je ne veux pas faire
tomber la moindre la moindre tête je
suis quelqu'un de pacifique
je pense que ben verdouble as préféré
sans doute la commission élyséenne où
monsieur macron va se contrôler lui-même
je le rappelle qu'on est dans un état de
droit que le parlement joue son rôle que
cette commission elle a été demandée par
les républicains que vous allez
travailler contre un déséquilibre
institutionnel
je viens de présider la commission d'
enquête sur l'attentât à la préfecture
police on en a parlé je vous le redis il
a été adopté à l'unanimité
donc je crois qu'on peut travailler
sereinement c'est toujours l'état
d'esprit qui m'a animé dans dans cet
hémicycle au n'est pas une autorité
judiciaire
nous sommes dans un équilibre de pouvoir
nous exerçons notre devoir et notre
pouvoir notre mission de contrôle de
l'exécutif penser quand je l'exerçais
syndicats auraient fait mieux
très clairement
comparons ce qui est comparable puisque
vous vous proposer cette ce dès ce débat
regardons ce qu'a fait nicolas sarkozy
quand il était président de la
république au moment de l'épisode de la
guerre de la grippe h1n1 on vit à la rue
on lui a reproché d'en avoir trop fait
mais il avait commandé les tests nous
avions à l'époque 1 milliard 700
millions de masques
regardez ce qu'a fait jacques chérèque
domine il avait comme ministre de la wii
mais justement parce qu'il ya eu ce
principe de précaution est ce qu'il vaut
mieux se préparer et que l'épidémie
heureusement n'arrive pas ou est ce
qu'il faudrait rester comme cela a été
fait depuis de trop nombreuses années
dans un état d'impréparation avec à
peine 100 millions de masques alors qu'
il y avait des rapports en 2018 qui
disons qu'il gouverne vous aviez
vraiment eu la preuve le pressentiment
que c'était important il aurait fallu le
dire avant c'est à dire que
vous expliquez que vous le saviez mais
après coup on attendait un peu
d'humilité dont nous ne le savions pas
qui a reçu les éléments qui dirige
l'international d'armes en disant
attention un problème en france le jour
où il ya une épidémie on est mal
préparée par ça me dit ça est ce que
nous avions les éléments est ce que les
notes des smartphones mais aussi la
direction générale de la santé
les notes et ce sera un travail de la
commission je veux pas le dévoiler
aujourd'hui je parle de la question des
masques bah c'est pas moi qui le dit le
professeur jean françois delfraissy
dimanche dans le jdd dit le confinement
a été mauvaise décision mais c'était la
seule possible compte tenu de l'état des
moyens dont nous disposions nous
faisions à l'époque il dit au début de
la crise début mars trois mille tests
par semaine nous pouvions faire trois
mille tests par semaine alors que
l'allemagne en faisait cinquante mille
la commission denquête regardera
pourquoi alors que nos voisins allemands
faisait cinquante mille tests nous nous
en étions à trois milles derrière il ya
beaucoup de décisions bureau 4x
bureaucratique totalement
contradictoires notamment sur les
autorisations qui sont tombés dans au
avec un pouvoir très centralisé qui a
mis des des semaines avant de de prendre
les bonnes décisions il ya la question
des masques nous regarderons sereinement
pourquoi encore une fois depuis que
xavier bertrand avait mis le plan
pandémie qui a été le plan avec une
vraie doctrine sous la présidence de
jacques chirac en 2005 c'était la grippe
avions donc c'est bien ça fait dix ans
pour l'équipe de départ on pourra pas
faire d' assurer sous leur surveillance
hawkeye a pas de reproche à faire on
peut vous savez moi je suis prêt à faire
sur la gestion de la crise économique
sur la gestion des crises sanitaires sur
la façon dont on a protégé les français
face à la délinquance sauver je pense
que leurs ébats narc n était plus on
sort et le pib conséquence voilà pour ça
peut-être bien de retrouver le pouvoir
merci beaucoup eric ciotti ce qui est
bien c'est que serait cp on va pouvoir
suivre minute par minute chacune de ces
auditions de la commission denquête donc
vous êtes le rapporteur sur le coville
19 et la gestion par le gouvernement de
cette crise sanitaire
va maintenant s'intéresser à une date le
10 juillet prochain c'est la date que le
gouvernement a finalement choisi pour
sortir de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
c'est le billet de tomate est prêt qui
nous explique tout dans sa journée à
l'assemblée
oui exactement myriam le gouvernement a
décidé de ne pas prolonger l'état
d'urgence sanitaire au delà de la date
prévue aujourd'hui dans la loi je vais
vous expliquer tout ça c'était donc la
nouvelle du jour le 10 juillet prochain
l'état d'urgence sanitaire va prendre
fin vous savez l'état d'urgence a été
décrété le 24 mars dernier pour faire
face à l'épidémie de coronavirus cette
semaine donc qu'ils vont bientôt prendre
fin
parce que l'épidémie recule cette fin de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire est au fond
de nouvelles positives parce qu'elle
signifie que nous avons au fond n'ont
pas encore gagné la bataille mais
marquer des points contre le colis de 19
alors du côté des députés la nouvelle
est plutôt bien accueillie même si
certains expriment des réserves dans la
mesure où l'exécutif nous expliquer
qu'il fallait apprendre à vivre avec le
co lead et donc à partir du moment où ça
devient la situation ordinaire il faut
que ce soit la loi ordinaire qui
prévalent et bien nous en sommes là et
donc oui il est temps de sortir de
l'état d'urgence il prévoit même de
remplacer cette prolongation par un
projet de loi qui sera encore atteint
soir au liberté le dis aujourd'hui il
est en 2d confiné il est temps de partir
de l'état d'urgence il est temps de
retrouver les libertés à cause de cet
état d'urgence il y avait beaucoup de
restrictions des libertés
et puis surtout un parlement qui vivait
en mode réduit avec des textes de loi
qui ne pouvait pas être étudier
tranquillement alors en réalité c'est
une sortie progressive de l'état
d'urgence à compter du 10 juillet le
gouvernement va se doter pour quatre
mois d'outils pour prévenir en cas de
reprise épidémique
d'abord en obligeant les français a
toujours porté un masque dans les
transports en commun en continuant de
restreindre certains rassemblements dans
des lieux publics est également en
continuant la fermeture de certains
espaces privés comme des discothèques
alors est ce que ces restrictions de
libertés individuelles sont utiles au
moment où l'épidémie recule on a posé la
question à la présidente de la
commission des lois
bonjour ya les banques privées est ce
que vous comprenez que certains dans
l'opposition se plaignent encore de
restriction de liberté
je crois qu'il faut être quand même
extrêmement prudents parce qu'on voit
bien
que dans tout le cours de ces dernières
semaines et derniers mois les
recommandations varier les la
connaissance que l'on a de cette
épidémie a varié donc les certitudes
d'aujourd'hui ne sont pas forcément les
certitudes de demain donc je pense qu'il
faut être extrêmement prudent on assiste
oui un reflux de l'épidémie mais il faut
rester prudent il faut rester très
attentif très vigilant et je crois que
c'est ce texte là qui pourra permettre
cela pourra tout à fait complet ce
projet de loi qui a été présenté ce
matin en conseil des ministres arrivera
ici à l'assemblée nationale dans
l'hémicycle le 17 juin prochain pour
être débattu par les députés
s'il est voté il entrera en vigueur donc
le 10 juillet prochain
mais ça on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
dans ma journée à l'assemblée
allez cette question à présent et s'il
n'y avait bientôt plus de quotidiens ni
de magazines dans nos kiosques la menace
est sérieuse pas seulement à cause du
coronavirus mais également à cause de la
faillite de presstalis
qu'est ce que c'est presstalis pourquoi
il est en crise donc en grève d'ailleurs
avec la cgt du livre
c'est un dossier complexe c'est un
dossier très important parce que c'est
un drame qui se joue pour les lecteurs
que nous sommes pour les kiosquiers pour
les éditeurs des journalistes on en
parle avec vous frédérick cassegrain
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être là vous
êtes le directeur de la publication de
l'hebdomadaire marianne et le président
de la coopérative de distribution des
magazines actionnaire majoritaire de
presstalis vous dialoguez ce soir avec
pierre-yves bournazel bonsoir député
agir ensemble de paris et vous avez
écouté ce matin
le p dg de presstalis qui était
auditionné à l'assemblée je vous donne
la parole dans un instant juste après
cette mise au point où on en a besoin
tout de même en images signées clément
perreault et nathalie gloire sisteron
dans les alpes-de-haute-provence
bienvenue dans une maison de la presse
pratiquement sans presse rayon
actuellement deux quotidiens nationaux
absolument vide quelques hebdomadaires
c'est tout ce pognon
d
titres phares comme l'équipe qui sont
absentes de nos rayons depuis plus de
quatre semaines et entre 15 et 20% de
moins de chiffre d'affaires pour le
produit presse on saura en sortie de
confinement ou c'est qu'on avait déjà
fait des chiffres pour le mois de mars
-2 62% pour le mois d'avril - 68%
envoyer un petit peu avec espoir cette
période qui arrivait de déconfinement
est catastrophique dans tout le sud-est
comme ici à marseille des milliers de
points de vente sont dans la même
situation dans les arrière boutiques des
invendus s'entassent dans la tente
d'être remboursés aux marchands de
journaux
à l'origine de cette situation les
difficultés financières de presstalis le
principal groupe français de
distribution de presse est en
redressement judiciaire
un plan de sauvetage est proposée l'état
mettrait plusieurs millions d'euros sur
la table
le pdg du groupe est venu le défendre ce
matin devant les députés de la
commission aux affaires culturelles
le nouveau presstalis va démarrer avec
un un nouveau bilan remis à zéro et une
trésorerie positive grâce aux apports de
l'état encore une fois dans les jours
qui viennent
le tribunal de commerce de paris
examinera les offres de reprise de
presstalis et nous espérons que la
nouvelle structure sera opérationnelle
au plus tard début juillet des propos
qui n'ont pas totalement rassuré les
députés échaudés depuis longtemps par la
gestion du groupe
l'histoire de presstalis de ces quinze
dernières années pourrait s'apparenter à
une longue descente aux enfers les plans
sociaux se succèdent décision judiciaire
et l'associent et rien n'y fait
la société ne n'arrive pas à se relever
la crise de presstalis n'est pas
nouvelle la principale messagerie la
seule à assurer la distribution des
quotidiens est toujours dans une
situation très critique et la période
qui s'ouvre est définitivement celle de
la dernière chance
au delà des vendeurs de journaux le
sauvetage de presstalis sera décisif
pour l'avenir de la presse déjà
fragilisés
ce qui est grave c'est qu'on fait mourir
par le bas c'est à dire par la base par
les points de vente
si les points de vente demain n'arrive
pas à survivre comment la presse va se
reconstruire dans cette région c'est ça
qui est très grave
moi si le point de vente il vend pu mais
magazine je suis mort en fait je vais
pas aller les vendre moi tout seul dans
mon petit coin j'en vendrais 3 c'est ce
vendredi que le tribunal de commerce de
paris devrait se prononcer sur le plan
de sauvetage alors avant de parler d'un
plan de sauvetage on va essayer de
comprendre ce qui se passe le diagnostic
de la situation auprès d'un casgrain
expliquer tout ce qui se passe sur le
terrain un quart du territoire qu'il a
plus de deux journaux c'est pas rien
c'est un drame c'est un drame pour
l'information qui est entraîné dans la
faillite de presstalis qui souffrent le
plus aujourd'hui alors qu'ils souffrent
le plus dans le temps présent ce sont
les diffuseurs de presse les diffuseurs
de presse de tout le couloir rhodanien
et de toute la zone de marseille ne sont
pas livrés depuis maintenant quatre
semaines donc ce sont des gens qui
pendant la période du confinement ont
bossé vraiment de manière extrêmement
avec des restes et jeux en tant que
représentant d'un journal comme marianne
je peux vous dire que nous en sommes
très heureux puisque on a très bien
vendu sur pendant cette période là
depuis les confinement de puits de
déconfinement la liquidation des dépôts
c'est à dire des gens qui livrait
ces points de vente a entraîné donc des
mouvements de grève
des mouvements de grève assez sauvage
puis que des dépôts ont été attaqués des
camions de journaux on est attaqué c'est
la cgt du livre s'est mis en grève
500 personnes sur le carreau reste à
entraîner il faut aussi reconnaître que
le licenciement de ces gens là a été
fait de manière assez brutale du jour au
lendemain ils ont appris que y perdaient
leur boulot et bien sûr c'est comme une
poudrière on sortait d'une période de
confinement où tout le monde avait enfin
énormément travaillé et on se retrouve
en plein de déconfinement on leur dit du
jour au lendemain ils ont appris à 1
vendredi à 15 heures que ça s'arrêtait
pour eux et donc certains des baux ont
été attaqués certains dépôts attaquer et
les marchands de journaux sont plus sûrs
et donc les causes qui souffrent
évidemment celui les ans 8 ans de la
chaîne bien sûr toute la chaîne de
distribution en augmentant chanteur bien
en tant qu'éditeur ben on perd bien sûr
nos ventes sur ces territoires là en
plus de la chute de la maison presstalis
parce que la chute de maisons passalis
c'est une créance de 120 millions
d'euros qui est perdu pour l'éditeur il
faut expliquer puisque vous êtes
actionnaire c'est une coopérative
actionnaire majoritaire 75 % pour les
magazines au fond presstalis vaudois de
l'argent combien l'argent que le client
donne dans un kiosque pour payer son
journal et une partie qui revient
l'éditeur hélas cet argent presstalis
l'a confisquée et l'a perdu tout
simplement donc l'éditeur
les éditeurs de presse quotidienne et
magazine attendent enfin une créance d'à
peu près 120 millions d'euros 120
millions 120 millions d'euros qu'ils ne
reverront jamais donc
donc ça veut dire que pendant toute
cette période vous saviez profond vous
alliez vendre à perte enfin nous avons
édité des des journaux mais exactement
donc ce qu'il fasse alors que vous avez
augmenter les ventes
bien sûr cette présence y est arrivé
s'est pressée d'arriver dans les points
de vente et l'argent n'est pas remonté
alors quand vous êtes un éditeur un
éditeur indépendant c'est votre petite
entreprise vous êtes comme franck annese
vous êtes comme eux
à d les deux cas mentonnière pour point
de vue comme un cerveau d'éditeurs
peut-être propriétaire de journal et
vous aimons prise d'eau gens nous
reviendrons
vous allez perdre 1 2 ou 3 millions
d'euros dans votre résultats
d'entreprises et bien pour certaines
entreprises
c'est la mort assurée aussi quand vous
êtes appuyé par un grand groupe
industriel comme sont un certain nombre
d'éditeurs de presse en france
las pour eux bon c'est une mauvaise
année mais l'année prochaine sera
peut-être me laver un ordre de grandeur
combien de magazines en france un petit
magazine risquent de mourir de cette
crise
on estime autour de 30% des magazines
qui pourrait ne pas se relever de cette
opération
bournazel pourquoi personne n'en parle
quand même un quart du territoire qui
n'a pas qui n'a pas accès à la presse le
droit à l'information les lecteurs sont
sont pénalisés on a parlé des kiosquiers
ya une indifférence générale c'est
dramatique ce qui se passe oui on en
parle ce soir on en a parlé ce matin à
l'assemblée nationale il ya un sujet
financier qui vient d'être évoquée il
faudra d'ailleurs regarder de près ce
qui s'est exactement passé parce que il
ya eu quand même des déconvenues
successives dans la gestion de
presstalis il ya une question économique
et social qui est la question des
éditeurs des diffuseurs et de leurs
salariés
c'est une question quand même essentiel
et puis il ya une question de vision de
la société dans laquelle on veut vivre
qui évidemment s'attache à la liberté de
s'informer à la liberté de la presse et
ces sujets nous préoccupe c'est la
raison pour laquelle avec d'autres
collègues ce matin nous les avons relayé
moi je suis très attaché par exemple au
point de vente aux marchands de journaux
aux kiosquiers qui sont évidemment des
éléments essentiels notre cohésion
sociale qui rendent beaucoup de services
aussi qui sont très utiles dans nos
quartiers
je suis inquiet pour leur avenir et donc
évidemment la situation actuelle les
fragilise encore plus il faut les
soutenir
il faut réinventer aussi un modèle qui
permette du haut en bas de la chaîne de
pouvoir permettre à chacun de pouvoir
vivre de son métier faire ça dure tout
de même en quoi un député peut faire
pression sur l'état sur le gouvernement
pour au moins que le problème
brel une table dans l'agenda panique
lance justement l'état le gouvernement
on a plutôt en tout cas une oreille
attentive
il faut le dire le ministre notamment de
la culture franck riester est très
attentif il ya eu des actes notamment
sur le plan financier et des garanties
et qui sont nécessaires et ce en l'état
évidemment la situation serait l'état
jusque catastrophique est encore pire
qu'aujourd'hui
maintenant il faut porter une vision
nouvelle et que ce qu'on a à construire
dans les années quand on parlait de la
vision nouvelle mais un mot quand même
sur le diagnostic ce qu'il faut
expliquer c'est que six presstalis et
dépose le bilan ce parce que le modèle
économique de la presse a complètement
changé aujourd'hui on lit on lit en
ligne oui et donc les quotidiens profite
davantage de la publicité sur les sites
et de vent debout
beaucoup moins en kiosque et ça a des
conséquences le système précédent c'est
un système qui était monté à la fin de
la guerre pour distribuer d'abord les
quotidiens donc c'est un système qui est
construit pour distribuer des quotidiens
toutes les nuits sur l'ensemble du
territoire national
et là malheureusement enfin c'est pas
malheureusement c'est d'ailleurs une
logique c'est comme dans tous les cas
pour tous les quotidiens du monde
le consommateur lit de moins en moins de
papier journal
elie maintenant son quotidien sur des
tablettes ou sur son téléphone portable
en revanche pour la presse magazine
c'est tout à fait différent
la presse magazine dresse une presse
attaché à lect à un lectorat attachés au
papier dont on a c'est vrai baisse de
nos diffusion comme tous les hommes tous
les éditeurs mais nettement moins donc
les magazines ont davantage besoin de
réaliser ce menons ce 75% vous avez au
capital 25-27 pour pour les quotidiens
mais il a l'impression qu'il ya deux
logiques qui s'affrontent qui
contribuent à cette crise pourquoi vous
n'arrivez pas à vous entendre magazine
souris quotidien les besoins sont
différents
un quotidien a besoin de distribuer
toutes les nuits quand un quotidien du
soir où un quotidien du matin avant des
cent mille exemplaires il ya dix ans il
en vend plus que 25000 mais les
kilomètres les voitures de livraison
les ouvriers qui travaillent la nuit
pour faire ses pâques et ils sont
toujours là donc les coûts n'ont pas
baissé et ça devient maintenant
insupportable ses coûts et c'est vrai
que on a besoin de cette presse
quotidienne parce que c'est presque
diène c'est ce qui fait vivre notre
démocratie notre république
mais la presse magazine là aussi vous
avez besoin d'une presse magazine parce
que la presse magazine c'est aussi
d'après d'information politique et
générale mais c'est aussi d'après
scientifiques aussi d'apprécier dick
capc et cette presse magazine prenez en
charge d'une certaine manière les coûts
de distribution des quotidiens
nous sommes dans un système coopératif
ces coûts ne sont plus supportables on
ne peut plus payer
il n'ya plus assez d'argent donc soit
les quotidiens paie leurs vrais coûts de
distribution et le paie grâce à l'état
parce que l'état prend en charge et
offre un serbe de subventions mais nous
presse magazine
on peut plus continuer à travailler de
cette manière là et deuxièmement le
consommateur change
autrefois vous aviez des gens qui
étaient abonnées au quotidien qui a
acheté tous les jours le quotidien chez
le marchand de journaux
maintenant c'est des achats de plus en
plus épisodique il comprendre le modèle
économique pour marianne combien vous
donner est bien pour ma part la
distribution du journal
je vais vous dire je donne à peu près
40% sur un jean un journal est énorme
oui mais le coût distribution de
marianne se fait sur deux jours un
quotidien ça se fait sur une nuit et je
pense que dans d'autres 40% aussi et
dans cette affaire marianne va perdre
huit cent mille euros pour une
entreprise qui fait huit cent mille
euros pour une entreprise qui est juste
à l'équilibré
je veux dire sans actionnaires cette
entreprise ferme et comment vous faites
c'est l'état qui vous donne un coup de
main non là on se tourne vers
l'actionnaire on se tourne vers notre
actionnaire pour dire est-ce que vous
pouvez nous aider une actionnaire de
marc de maria riesch
ce qui n'est pas le cas de la grande
grande majorité des éditeurs de
magazines
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire alors il ya 2
il ya deux messagerie sur le marché la
première c'est presstalis la deuxième
semaine bp qu'il paie mmp les lyonnais
messagerie lieu de ce prince alla
on essaye de les unir pour créer une
entité plus plus forte économiquement ça
je crois que c'est un travail qui doit
être élaboré avec les professionnels
donc nous on est là pour relayer leurs
attentes et voir quelles le modèle
économique social qui peut fonctionner
sur un plan évidemment financier mais
aussi pour protéger un certain de
salariés et permettent que cette liberté
d'être informées cette liberté de la
presse soit effectif partout et sur tout
le territoire carte on voit ce qui est
en train de se passer dans notre pays on
a vu le reportage tout à l'heure c'est
sidérant qu'on en soit arrivé là
sidérant aussi parce que cette
particulier presstalis le poids des
syndicats est très fort il ya parfois
des techniques un peu de prises d'otages
qui sont fréquentes au qu'est ce qu'on
fait quand on est juste heras et prises
d'otages je peux que les condamnés et
c'est pas une manière de faire et vous
n'entendrez jamais dans ma bouche le
soutien à ce genre de méthode mais là il
ya aussi d'abord il faut le dire un
problème économique et social et que des
personnes à qui on explique que leur
emploi est terminée et que le système
n'est plus viable
forcément ça va créer des problèmes et
des tensions donc je crois qu'il faut
s'attaquer aux racines du problème de
poser le diagnostic comme on a essayé de
le faire et qu'on l'avait très bien fait
tout à l'heure regardez avec tous les
acteurs et les professionnels
comment du début à la fin de la chaîne
on peut permettre à chacun de pouvoir
travailler et de vivre de son travail
le pdg du reste adjoint de soutiens
évidemment de l'état mais on a aussi
besoin de que les partenaires privés
s'engagent aussi parce que c'est aussi
une vision de la société et puis il ya
des nouveaux enjeux il ya de l'enjeu
écologique notamment dont on pourrait
parler sur la question des invendus et
beaucoup de travail qui a été fait il ya
des propositions qui peuvent être portés
en tout cas moi je suis en contact avec
un certain nombre de personnes qui
réfléchissent sur ce sujet pour
alimenter les professionnels de deux
propositions prochainement alors le p dg
de presstalis a parlé ce matin de la
mise en place d'une structure
opérationnelle en juillet l'état va
financer le démarrage de nouvelles
messageries avec 200 millions sur la
table ça va suffire ou pas qu'est ce que
vous voudrez qu'est ce que vous attendez
je veux dire presstalis est l'héritier
où l'héritière d'une structure qui se
plaisent nmpp
mais l'objectif pour nous c'est d'avoir
une structure pérenne qui durent dans le
temps
il ya deux acteurs sur
marché à presstalis et les mails p est
ce que c'est la propulsion des magazines
c'était celle ci et c'est toujours celle
ci il faut absolument qu'on se rapproche
des mails p qu'on arrête ses guerres
entre les deux sociétés de messagerie
qu'on arrête de replâtrer en permanence
le titanic presstalis et concret et
unique structure de distribution de la
presse alors ça va pas rapprochement
avec les mails paix discussions avec les
mails p les systèmes informatiques les
systèmes commerciaux la discussion le
syndicat du livre il est là qu est ce
qui peut nous reprocher à nous éditeurs
le syndicat de ne pas avoir une vision
vision pour l'avenir
est-ce que de leur dire vous êtes
licencié vous partez mais sans leur
expliquer la vision qu'on a sur la
structure c'est extrêmement frustrant et
c'est violent donc l'objectif c'est
quand même d'avoir une organisation qui
soit pérenne dans le temps on sait que
les quotidiens vont petit à petit
baisser leur tirage c'est très bien
qu'ils vont basculer sur le numérique
dans les années à venir
il faut continuer à construire un avenir
pérenne mais avec l'ensemble de la
presse magazine donc s'allier pour
éviter la catastrophe
pourquoi pas tout cas le débat sur la
table je vous ai entendus à plusieurs
reprises et évoquer cette idée il faut
que tous les professionnels et puissent
exprimer leur point de vue moi j'ai pas
de tabou à partir de monde faire
fonctionner un système
je pense aussi qu'il ya un vrai travail
à faire parce que dans la transformation
de votre modèle et notamment vers le
numérique c'est comment conserver une
stratégie aussi pour pour le papier que
ce soit pour les quotidiens ou pour les
magazines avec deux problématiques très
différentes
je pense aussi que ça passe par beaucoup
l'éducation je pense qu'il est important
que très jeune à l'école on apprenne que
la liberté de la presse c'est absolument
essentielle dans une démocratie et que
donc il faut d'abord apprendre à
s'informer et avoir le goût de la
pluralité de l'information et donc
d'avoir la curiosité et longvic d'aller
lire des journaux de lire des magazines
et les lire en ligne des comprendre la
société par soi même le monde la presse
est important que c'est parti très tôt
parce que je trouve que les nouvelles
générations s'informent beaucoup plus
vite qu'avant mais de manière moins
précise et peut-être que là il ya
quelque chose à faire
le monde d'après pour la presse c'est le
numérique à 100%
non je crois à l'avenir du papier
je crois que
le papier sur la presse magazine a
toutes ses chances sur le pré scudier
oui mais c'est la quotidienne qui
s'ouvre aux états unis il ya des états
entiers qui ont vu disparaître la presse
la presse quotidienne
tout à fait mais la presse magazine vous
avez une presse hebdomadaire mensuelle
ou trimestrielle que vous gardez que
vous conservez c'est la relation entre
les deux supports est très différente
l'achat d entre eux dit est très dur on
achète le week-end ses magazines pour
les feuilleter tranquillement tandis qu
on lit les quotidiens aux lignes c'est
très beau c'est comme ça que vous voyez
les usages et vous moi j'aime bien le
matin avoir le parisien le figaro ou
libé j'aime bien avoir à 14h le monde
puisque j'ai la chance d'être parisien
et j'aime bien le le jeudi le mercredi
il y avait l'express le jeudi arrivé
avec tous les autres hebdos et puis le
week-end avec marianne le figaro
magazine et cetera
bien sûr voilà l'ops on va tous ces
sites et le point pour les mêmes valeurs
actuelles pour pas se faire engueuler
mais bien sûr quand on a eu cette
éducation et ce goût de lire les
magazines ou les quotidiens je pense que
ça reste et c'est très important que
dans une nouvelle génération on donne ce
goût cet intérêt à la presque tiens on
espère évidemment que les préfets
pourront consulter leurs journaux tous
leurs journaux magazines au quotidien
dans les kiosques du sud de la france
parce que quelque chose me dit qu'ils
seront nombreux cet été sur les plages
de du sud est et de la provence
vous restez avec nous on va regarder un
tout petit peu ce qui se passe du côté
des britanniques avec alex taylor alex
est avec nous vous le savez c'est notre
chroniqueur francophile et maintenant
français même s'il est aussi un
britannique
alors la distribution de la presse alex
c'est à peu près comment dire des
problèmes similaires pas tout à fait ils
ont d'autres problèmes
au royaume uni c'est ça oui brillamment
on comprend assez mal la presse
britannique
en france d'abord ya beaucoup plus de
journaux vendus tous les gens 6.5
millions des journaux comme dawson ou de
mails par exemple thivras tous les jours
1,3 million c'est plus chacun que
l'ensemble de la presse française
nationale réunit donc il ya 12 journaux
tous les jours les lecteurs aussi sans
beaucoup moins fidèles si en france on
achète le figaro un jour il ya peu de
chances qu'on achète libé lendemain en
grande bretagne il faut que c'est jonas
pâte
c'est pour ça que les unes sont souvent
plus racoleuses et que les opinions sont
plus fortes et une presse d'opinion
en grande bretagne on l'a vu surtout
avec le bike site où 80% je pars en
terme de circulation de la presse était
pour le break site donc ccc cela était
donc c'est cela votre revirement
oui il ya eu d'abord quelques
changements de propriétaires tout
simplement plus spectaculaire s'est dit
exprès si vous vous tapez dans google
des express et lé mot migron vous allez
tomber sur d une assise racistes pendant
des années sur les migrants en grande
bretagne et bien changement radical de
temps parce que nous vaut d'être en chef
gary jones va a dit qu'il n'arrivait pas
à dormir quand il pensait à tous et à
tous ce racisme d'enclos journal publie
désormais quelques articles même
sympathique sur tous ces gens venus
d'ailleurs qui nous aident dans les
hôpitaux et accueillir nos fruits et
légumes puis le corona est passée par là
aussi pour de mails par exemple grand
pitbull du pack city et beaucoup booster
johnson devant les élections et qui m'a
tant cette semaine fait un article sur
la débâcle de sa gestion de la crise
corona et puis je suis tombé des nues ce
week end dans ce journal qui a tant fait
pour le bike site qui ose lancer une
pétition signée par une brique sitters
l'ex ministre de l'agriculture en
grande-bretagne pétition contre les
poulets au chlore et l'abaissement des
normes britanniques c'est à dire
européenne dans la nourriture faut
parfois aussi chercher la femme si vous
savez que l'une des plumes les plus
renommés de ce délit mais elle s'appelle
sarah vine qu'il épouse du ministre
michael gove qui lui se verrait bien un
jour à la place du dit johnson donc
comme on dit en anglais look force de
romaine
merci alex
c'est ça peut être ça notre avenir une
presse d'opinion une presse très très
marquée politiquement primorié manning
au royaume uni où sévit le marianne
c'est un peu ça il ya un bruit et pas
caricatural
marianne est un journal réfléchi lorsque
vous regardez la presse britannique vous
avez une presse quotidienne des tabloïds
et qui sont extrêmement agressif que
sans vergogne on pensait que la
rédactrice en chef et de la femme d'un
enfin c'est quand même passé on verrait
pas ça en france on éviterait peut-être
mais en revanche nous avons nous en
france une presse magazine beaucoup
beaucoup plus riche que nous sommes le
pays au monde où nous avons la plus
forte densité de presse magazine bien
vous avez des titres surtout en france
et c'est une vraie richesse dire que
vraiment presse quotidienne nationale
qui se résume à une dizaine de titres là
une presse quotidienne régionale qui
présente aussi qui est très présente en
et vous avez une presse magazine
extrêmement riche
on a un pays oui on est un pays très
riche
merci beaucoup il faut soutenir la
presse par ailleurs il faut l'acheter
les lieux les lecteurs étaient nombreux
mais malheureusement est un auteur ou un
peu quitté la scène pendant pendant la
crise sanitaire en sauna presse quand
même plurielle et de qualité très bon
choix lors modèle britannique je ne
connais pas bien mais de ce que j'en
comprends quand même je crois que notre
modèle est quand même meilleur merci
beaucoup merci messieurs pour ce
décryptage de ce sujet complexe mais ô
combien important c'est la fin de cette
émission on vous promet de diffuser le
jour d'après comme prévu avec david jay
sur le retour en force des états nations
on le fera dès demain sans faute
très belle soirée documentaire sur lcp
et à demain
[Musique]